Ciao maryners e benvenuti in un nuovissimo
video in thailandia oltre a visitare ho comprato anche delle cosine
soprattutto delle cosine che riguardano il mondo beauty
e soprattutto
due maschere
giusto due di numero e oggi oltre alle maschere farò vedere anche altri prodotti beauty molto particolari
che ho trovato appunto in thailandia prima di passare alle maschere io
partirei da questa crema per il corpo eh sì ragazzi è una crema corpo al gusto chupa chups
all'aroma di chupa chups
Fragola dice che ha la vitamina C e acido ialuronico io ci credo molto poco poco poco
L'estetista civica direbbe non vi mettete la merda addosso ma noi vogliamo provare la merda ma che colore è
allora la texture é molto molto...
allora sembra di spalmarsi lo yogurt ai frutti di bosco
Beh come yogurt é buono
quasi quasi gli do una leccata allora sicuramente d'estate é il metodo migliore per farsi mangiare vivi dalle zanzare
Ma io veramente mi chiedo allora il profumo è molto buono però è veramente troppo nauseante
no infatti sa di gomma da masticare piú che altro non si assorbe mai ragazzi menomale che c'é l'acido ialuronico
One year later
Per me è no cioé nel senso non capisco l'utilità menomale che ci sono i kleenex a portata di mano
secondo me la texture è molto buona dici nel senso che come crema idratante non è molto grassa il problema è  l'odore
dovete sapere che nelle creme che comprate non ci deve essere mai
un ingrediente qua è il primo : la paraffina
dopo l'acqua c'è la paraffina liquida non va bene non va bene crema corpo chupa chups
Bocciata un altro prodottino che mi ha incuriosito molto
arcova è un negozio coreano è un gel detergente per il viso una schiuma con il flaconcino con già la spugnetta quindi praticamente
funziona così lo faccio su edoardo perché io sono truccata vai
Ok
e ci laviamo il viso
ma che che avanguardia é molto fresca la sensazione é già fresco di suo come detergente però è
comodissimo no sciacquiamo con una velina per vedere come lascia la pelle
qual è la sensazione non c'ho più niente? Wow
é liscia? é fresca?
é freschissima é molto fresca la sensazione cioè pensavo ci fosse ancora il prodotto talmente era fresco
via il trucco mi vado a struccare per provarla no la proverò stasera molto buono buono
posso vedere l'inci?si prego
Non si capisce una mazza schiuma detergente con
Applicatore come si chiama spugnetta
autopulente super promossa io la devo provare ma mi sembra che è liscio? tocca
raga miracolosa
Andiamo avanti allora io voglio vederti con questo
Sembra qualcosa di
strano ma in realtà è molto più semplice di quello che
immaginate è un massaggiatore per la faccia eccolo
é bello oddio ti metto un siero che peró ti devo spalmare perché é super liquido
Poco basta che se no non scivola
Qui vedete chiudete a seconda della grandezza del viso e andate a
massaggiare dal basso verso l'alto con un'azione anti rughe sembra una televendita
soltanto per oggi
a 9 euro e 90 con un semplice massaggio
ringiovanirete di 10 anni e lifterete la vostra faccia senza filler
promozione straordinaria
brand arcova adesso lo voglio provare anch'io dico anche col trucco
guarda come massaggia mi sento donatella versace
ah qui c'é lo specchio
Penso che passerò le mie serate davanti a netflix con questo prossimamente é super rilassante
avete presente quello per la testa questo è meglio
perché la testa è rilassante però non ha nessun beneficio vero invece secondo me questo qua cioé
Proprio tipo mi sveglio alla mattina con 18 anni
Andiamo avanti con
Questa figata sapete che quando si parla di disney io sono in prima linea
sono delle maschere appunto con non so se la faccia della principessa
o si no c'è tutta la principessa e delle decorazioni belle quale proviamo dai una la dobbiamo provare
per me una?
la provi tu sopra il trucco giusto per farla vedere
allora proviamo biancaneve che é quella che mi piace di meno
e ce la togliamo
ah hanno i gusti allora belle é alla rosa buona jasmine al caviale
d'oro
urca cosa vorrà dire cenerentola al collagene adoro proprio
ariel perla nera biancaneve proprio basic
alla mela
e non so se dovremmo ridere o piangere ma nel dubbio apriamo
non sa di maschera sa di mela avariata amo immagina se me la metto ed é velenosa
come la mela di biancaneve che viaggi comunque tu eh
è un peccato però usarle
Beh
Allora qualità ne ho viste di migliori esatto diciamo che secondo me
Comunque mi piace molto marina che col metodo scientifico lei
si mette una maschera col trucco sopra e certo diciamo che io non avevo visto bene la confezione
mi immaginavo che fossero però proprio con la faccia della principessa così è un po tipo découpage cioè un pó dei fiori un pó di
come la senti? fresca fresca fresca
peró l'odore effettivamente non é buono
oh ma sono ancora marina pensavo di cantare agli usignoli
Quando devi buttare via le maschere se non sono completamente
asciutte con la maschera ti passi anche sul collo e sul decolté
perché comunque il prodotto che é rimasto nella maschera é sempre utile lo so lo lascia lì dopo il video lo farò
andiamo avanti andiamo avanti con una cosa non thailandese ma che qua non avevo ancora trovato è di
origins maskimizer si chiama quindi è un ottimizzante della pelle pre maschera un primer per le maschere viso
In realtà buono buono il profumo
è uno spray fresco non oleoso no no assolutamente e visto che hai il pre maschera tocca me adesso
secondo me é arrivato il momento
non ve la faccio vedere la metto
Sorridi in camera
Dovrebbe essere una foca prego puoi guardare
Allora è animal acqua mask allora
sempre di arcova apparte che l'ho già assaggiata un pó in bocca quindi é buona anche al gusto é buona
una cosa molto bella che trovo di questa maschera é che il
Cotone é molto spesso a differenza di
altre maschere che sono troppo sottili e ti s si appiccicano questo cotone é molto spesso
ma poi si sente che é super idratante si applica facilmente
non ha un buon odore
Però l'odore nelle masche non è proprio fondamentale soprattutto
questa
alla bava di lumaca
secondo me non avrà un buonissimo odore però in thailandia va non di moda di più
questa qui ha in particolare acqua glicerina estratto di camomilla e
secrezione di lumaca
filtrata e sodio ialuronato
bava di lumaca fa benissimo ragazzi la cosa figa é che
qui in italia non ho ancora trovato I pacchetti con così tante maschere questo qua per esempio ne ha cinque ci sono?
no sono difficili da trovare forse dr jart
li fa però lí la maggior parte sono minimo 2
che infatti ogni volta che vado a prendere le maschere ne prendo una e già il giorno dopo è finita quando la metto quindi
dovete farlo anche qua in italia io posso togliermi un attimo la maschera secondo me no
perché qua arriva l'ultimo prodotto che è
Che ve lo dico a fare
ragazzi la
meraviglia
la meraviglia
pazzesca io sto veramente facendo tutto il video così
no questa é fighissima mano destra o mano sinistra
Che cosa mano destra o mano sinistra il tuo regalo
Mano sinistra
Siiii Adoro cioè io ho visto questa cosa e ho subito pensato a lui anche se non ho idea di quale sia
perché ha detto gli cade il collo no era figo perché a lui piacciono queste mascherine molto stile liberato quindi sembrava un pó quello
un pó miss keta però è una maschera che a quanto pare serve per
cioé secondo me é una roba tipo per i  punti neri può esser vediamo un attimo no lifting
è arrivata anche una certa per me quindi
fighissima questa cosa questo prodotto per la mascella
lifta e fa raggiungere
una grande elasticità
e
ti riporta alla tua forma originale in che senso vediamo almeno com'é dentro
ah due ce ne sono volo c'è anche una cartolina
con il
testimonial cioé ragazzi di cosa stiamo parlando
Molto bella ah vedi super black mask
ma praticamente tu la metti qua e lei ha questa funzione che secondo me lifta
e io l'ho presa invece rosa cioè me ne sono fregata delle caratteristiche
ho visto rosa e ho preso rosa però perché lei sorride e lui no
perché gli uomini non
sorridono mai fa io mi farei due domande dovremo la proveremo tutti e due e ci faremo
un facetime una bella foto nelle storie instagram
e poi ci continueremo a interrogare per tutta la vita su quali fossero le reali
proprietà di questa maschera e pubblicherò
anche tutte le maschere che ho comprato e che non vi ho fatto vedere perché sono tantissime vabe io magari mi tolgo la maschera
anche se mi dispiace un pochino vediamo l'effetto trucco
è un po come il 15 di agosto in città
detto questo noi ci vediamo al prossimo video e
iscrivetevi al canale per non perdere i prossimi video sulla skincare e noi vi mandiamo un bacione e
ricordate di seguirla su
instagram facebook tiktok seguite edo su instagram che è molto instagrammabile
Iscrivetevi al canale ragazzi perché devo arrivare a un milione quindi aiutatemi un bacione e io continuo a massaggiarmi ciao